I couldn't bring myself to sleep in our  bed alone we lost it ours  we're HR died we had a funeral maybe we  should give us all permission to grief  what are we gonna bury dead empty suit  in the lab it's up to us to protect this  city because there is no one else just  us trying to keep the city safe were  barely getting it done we need to bring  Barry back no Barry told us to keep  moving forward not to save you what is  your deal it's like you don't even want  him back you're certain that Barry is  even still alive  Pyrus he's gotta be you need to believe  that there is an answer for every  question Ares trying to send us a  message I know it  you guys strike the baby girl we just  need a little faith let's bring our boy  home  you need to prepare yourselves bury this  guy's no joke he said he wants to fight  the flood  we made you a new suit I'm gonna take it  for a spin  you